y
[Música]
rodrigo duterte se retira de la política
el presidente filipino conocido por su
letal represión antidrogas y su retórica
irreverente dejó claro que no aspirará a
la vicepresidencia tras el descontento
de la población esta medida alimenta los
rumores de que su hija podría lanzarse a
sucederlo en los próximos comicios
las disputas dentro del partido
demócrata en eeuu obligaron a suspender
la votación del proyecto de
infraestructura el presidente joe biden
visitó al capitolio este viernes para
solucionar las diferencias que podrían
entorpecer uno de los planes más
importantes de su agenda
eeuu superó las 700.000 muertes por
hobby 19 una cifra impulsada por la
variante delta del virus entre la
población que sigue sin querer aplicarse
la vacuna se estima que unos 70 millones
de estadounidenses elegibles para el
fármaco no lo han recibido
feliz fin de semana y bienvenidos a una
nueva emisión de noticias en francés 24
los saluda andrés meza muñoz y empezamos
en filipinas donde el presidente rodrigo
duterte anunció que se retira de la
política
el mandatario quien es conocido por su
retórica irreverente y su letal
represión contra las drogas abandonó sus
planes para presentarse a vicepresidente
en las elecciones de 2022 su intención
había provocado la ira de los opositores
ya que de llegar a la vicepresidencia
tendría que reemplazar al primer
mandatario en caso de muerte o
incapacidad y la constitución filipina
sólo permite un periodo presidencial de
seis años su retiro alimenta los rumores
de que su hija podría lanzarse para
sucederlo
el sentimiento abrumador del filipino es
que no estoy calificado y sería una
violación de la constitución eludir la
ley y el espíritu de la constitución y
así en obediencia a la voluntad de la
gente que después de todo me puso en la
presidencia de hace muchos años ahora le
digo a mis compatriotas que seguiré sus
deseos y hoy les anuncio mi retiro de la
política el presidente de eeuu joe biden
se reunió en el capitolio con los
demócratas del congreso para intentar
superar las divisiones que amenazan su
agenda económica y que tienen bloqueado
el proyecto de ley de infraestructura
del mandatario los demócratas
progresistas se niegan a votar sobre
infraestructura sin garantías sobre el
proyecto de gasto social y ambiental la
votación sigue bloqueada y no hay una
fecha establecida marina sardenya nos
cuenta más en el siguiente informe
sin votación en el congreso ni acuerdo
entre los demócratas pese a los
esfuerzos del presidente estadounidense
joe biden se trasladó hasta el capitolio
para negociar con los miembros de su
partido prometiendo que sus reformas
económicas y sociales serán aprobadas
por la cámara de representantes hacen
mil preguntas diferentes y todas son
legítimas te digo que lo vamos a lograr
no importa cuando no importa si en 6
minutos 6 días o 6 semanas vamos a
conseguirlo
la visita de biden para presionar sobre
el estancado proyecto de ley de
infraestructura responde a las
divisiones internas que sufren los
demócratas el ala progresista se niega a
votar sobre las infraestructuras hasta
que el congreso apruebe un proyecto de
ley de bienestar social y cambio
climático de unos 35 billones de dólares
en contraparte los moderados quieren
reducir el tamaño de la financiación del
paquete el mandatario reconoció que los
demócratas no tienen los votos
suficientes para apoyar ambos proyectos
aunque creo que hay muchos demócratas
frustrados ahora mismo por el hecho de
que yo wyden haya esperado tanto tiempo
para involucrarse
se puede herir pero no hiere de muerte a
la presidencia de bailén hay una serie
de actores aquí creo que incluso la
credibilidad de la presidenta de la
cámara de representantes- pelosi se
tambalea en cuanto a ser la negociadora
hábil e intocable como lo demuestra el
hecho de que hayan tenido que posponer
la votación sobre infraestructuras que
ella se empeñó en convocar té
con una estrecha mayoría en la cámara
del partido de baile no puede permitirse
perder demasiados votos en la
legislación sobre infraestructuras y es
poco probable que los republicanos del
congreso ayuden a aprobar los deseosos
de negar a byd en una victoria política
de cara a los comicios de medio término
en otras noticias de eeuu el país superó
las 700 mil muertes por kobe 19 este
viernes a pesar de que durante meses la
tasa de mortalidad descendió en las
últimas semanas los fallecimientos
aumentaron especialmente entre los
estados que mantienen tasas de
vacunación bajas
eeuu alcanzó otro hito oscuro al superar
las 700 mil muertes por kobe 19
esto significa que 100.000
estadounidenses han sucumbido al virus
desde mediados de junio en enero de 2021
los fallecimientos relacionados por el
hobbit 19 alcanzaron un máximo de 3000
diarios en junio se redujeron a unos 300
para que las cifras volvieran a casi
2000 muertes diarias este último aumento
se ha atribuido en parte a la
prevalencia de la variante delta del
virus pero también a una ralentización
de la vacunación durante el verano sólo
alrededor del 56% de los estadounidenses
han recibido ambas dosis y los datos
muestran que la mayoría de muertes se
produjeron entre los no vacunados los
estados sureños se han visto
especialmente afectados florida y texas
tienen la tasa de mortalidad más alta
del país con diferencia y mientras que
las hospitalizaciones y contagios han
comenzado a disminuir en las últimas
semanas los expertos advierten que en
los meses de invierno podría haber otro
aumento es probable que las bajas
temperaturas obliguen a las personas a
permanecer en interiores haciéndolas más
vulnerables a contagios y la llegada de
la temporada de gripe podría tensionar
aún más al sistema sanitario
kobe 19 ya causó más fallecimientos en
eeuu que la gripe española de 1918
algo que hace que sea la pandemia más
mortífera de la historia del país
a continuación otras noticias
relacionadas con el cobre 19 en el mundo
california se convertirá en el primer
estado de eeuu en exigir la vacuna para
estudiantes de 12 años en adelante la
medida entrará en vigencia una vez que
la agencia reguladora de medicamentos y
alimentos apruebe el fármaco para este
grupo poblacional ya que hasta ahora
sólo se aplica bajo uso de emergencia
argentina se suma a la lista de países
que vacunar a los más pequeños el
gobierno anunció que aplicará la vacuna
de la empresa china sino farm a niños de
entre 3 y 11 años que son alrededor de 6
millones en el país y espera que la
mayoría de ellos esté inoculada para
finales de año
pero por su parte empezará por aplicar
la dosis de refuerzo de la vacuna contra
el toby 19 al personal sanitario adultos
mayores de 65 años y otras personas con
enfermedades de riesgo el gobierno
también espera que entre noviembre y
diciembre pueda empezar a inocular a los
mayores de 12 años
y continúa el tránsito de emigrantes por
sur y centroamérica si eeuu provenientes
de brasil y chile miles deben cruzar la
intransitable selva del darién frontera
natural entre colombia y panamá para
continuar su viaje al norte
algunos de ellos no logran avanzar y
pierden su vida en la travesía andrés
granadillo tiene el reporte
cruzar la selva del darién una travesía
que no todos pueden lograr un grupo de
emigrantes perdió la vida intentando
cruzar el tramo más difícil del viaje a
eeuu
mencionan muchos lugares ellos mencionan
bajando una loma la loma de la muerte
también han mencionado que en algunas
ocasiones migrantes han tenido
accidentes a la loma en una pendiente
muy
tiene mucha pendiente y este han sufrido
algunos accidentes este año se han
recuperado al menos 44 cuerpos en darién
aquí hay personas que están caminando en
la selva y que tienen más de 60 años la
posibilidad de que tengo un ataque al
corazón porque tengo una infección son
alta o de que se caiga tengo una
fractura de cadera y no puede seguir
caminando y posteriormente queda
abandonado en la selva la cifra es más
alta que en años anteriores cuando la
cantidad de cuerpos encontrados era de
15 personas en promedio un triste
reflejo de la mayor ola de migración
irregular a través del darién en poco
más de una década
esta vez la ola es liderada por
haitianos provenientes de brasil o chile
que habían huido a estos países luego de
dejar haití tras el devastador terremoto
de 2010 las autoridades panameñas
estiman que más de 90.000 migrantes han
cruzado por el darién en lo que va de
2021 sin importar los peligros
advertencias y muertes todos los días
continúa el trayecto a pesar de las
recientes expulsiones y deportaciones
registradas desde la ciudad texana de
del río fronteriza con méxico
y con motivo del tercer aniversario de
la muerte del periodista saudita llama
al caso que este viernes se llevó a cabo
una vigilia cerca del capitolio
estadounidense en washington su
prometida hatice y exchange y se estuvo
presente durante el evento y pidió al
presidente joe biden cumplir su promesa
de obtener justicia por la muerte del
periodista allí cuestionó los lazos de
estados unidos con el príncipe heredero
de arabia saudita mohamed bin salman
quien es señalado de ordenar el
asesinato en el interior del consulado
saudita en estambul
y antes de despedirnos los invitamos a
visitar nuestra página web www puntos 24
punto com en portada detalles sobre las
disputas del partido demócrata que
retrasan la votación del plan de
infraestructura del presidente joe biden
y también detalles sobre la crisis
energética o la escasez de energía en
china
hasta aquí este informativo enfadado 24
quédense con nosotros
[Música]